hallo ihr lieben ich habe euch vor
kurzem ja den rote beete tipp gezeigt
und jetzt zeige ich euch zwei weitere
einer ist so richtig erfrischend mit
bill und körner käse und der andere das
ist ein paprika dip beide super lecker
und sehr schnell zubereitet und wir
starten wir zuallererst mit dem körner
käse tipp dafür benötigen wir körnigen
frischkäse joghurt den frühlingszwiebeln
gurken salz pfeffer und knoblauch und
ich habe schon mal ein bisschen arbeit
erledigt ich habe dell frühlingszwiebeln
und gurken schon mal vor geschnippelt je
kleiner und feiner desto besser und
jetzt werden alle zutaten einfach nur
miteinander verrührt
[Musik]
mit sind fast alle zutaten drin es gebe
ich nur noch salz pfeffer und knoblauch
rein und bei salz und pfeffer müsst ihr
einfach mal selber abschmecken
und der erste tipp ist fertig der hält
sich im kühlschrank drei tage der
schmeckt auch jeden tag total frisch und
lecker und ich will ihnen gleich noch um
sehr wenig schön und dann machen wir
weiter mit dem nächsten tipp für den
paprika dip benötigen wir frisch käse
joghurt klein gewürfelte rote paprika
frühlingszwiebeln paprika marc edel
süßes paprikapulver und salz auch hier
wieder das gleiche prinzip alle zutaten
miteinander verrühren wobei ich auch
hier wieder paprika und
frühlingszwiebeln im voraus schon mal
klein geschnitten habe
[Musik]
übrigens klappt das ganze auch wunderbar
mit tomatenmark aber mit paprika mack
ist alles so ein bisschen intensiver
es gibt mittlerweile auch beim türken
glaube ich tomaten und paprika mark im
mixed es schmeckt auch sehr gut habe ich
auch schon mal probiert aber original
also meine original variante ist halt
mit paprika mag
[Musik]
und fertig ist schon der paprika dip so
schnell ging mehr
und ich hab jetzt noch ein bisschen
schnittlauch und paprika übrig
gelassenen habt ihr mann gesehen wie
schön das aussieht diese farben dieser
mischmasch mischmasch okay ich bin da so
schön und ich geb dir gleich auf jeden
fall nach oben drüber wenn ich das ganze
sehr wir auch der paprika gibt sich drei
tage lang frisch im kühlschrank bei
detecon unglaublich lecker passt perfekt
zur grillsaison oder auch mal so
zwischendurch falls das ganze jetzt
nachmachen möchte schaut mal unten in
die infobox da stehen alle genauen
mengenangaben ansonsten freue ich mich
wie immer über fotos mit dem hashtag
iges kitchen auf instagram und bis zum
nächsten mal auf die gis kitchen tschüss
[Musik]